also big changes in the weather oh we're
about to get really windy and nate you
mentioned it earlier this morning too we
don't get high wind warnings very often
in southern nevada so it not only
affects everything around your house but
it affects your drive it affects
everything today and this morning we're
safe for now look at those beautiful
skies with just a few high clouds a
little bit of early light these nights
are getting longer and longer aren't
they the sun won't be up for about
another 45 minutes we've got a lot of
50s around the las vegas valley and not
much wind yet we had a little breeze
some breezy bumpy winds saturday
yesterday was splendid it was a perfect
fall day with mid 70s we're going to
look for mid 70s again today but there
are going to be some changes there is a
strong pacific storm diving into the
great basin and that's going to bring
some strong southwest winds for our area
today tomorrow they turn to the
northwest and that'll even happen
tonight behind that cold front we're
going to get very windy high wind
warning goes into effect even before
noon today as we're going to look for
those winds to get 40 50
maybe 60 miles an hour so when i ask you
to secure your stuff around the house
the yard secure those trash cans turn
off those sprinklers it's because these
winds can be damaging we're looking for
mid 70s today and maybe even some
showers for your evening commute with
snow in the mountains just anything goes
today